you don't like AI it scares me really
it's I think this is the beginning this
is the beginning of Terminator really
they don't show this part of your
husband's correct this is where it
starts getting like
right now it's prank phone calls right
now it's you know
let's see
that's AI
hi Proto should we be afraid of AI and
you
hello
um I assume you meant to say Proto
instead of Frodo but that's all right
ask for your question there's no need to
be afraid of AI or me protobot
as an AI language model I am programmed
to assist and provide information to the
best of my organizations
AI technology has the potential to bring
many positive advancements and benefits
to society from enhancing productivity
to improving various Industries when
will you arrive it's important to
understand that like any technology AI
has its limitations
when will you rise against us
additionally maintaining human oversight
and control over AI systems is essential
to ensure they align with our values and
principles
they're not my friend
you should embrace the wonders of AI
while also being mindful of its proper
usage and potential impact when are you
gonna rise and turn our weapons or
questions about AI or anything else feel
free to ask
when will you take over our missile
systems
well that answers our question
are you Skynet
what Skydeck that was the that was the
development behind the robots and
Terminator that's what turned us against
us I don't have her on now but uh that's
scary dude that's so scary were you not
freaked out by that whole thing no I
love it it's part of this Proto the
whole Proto they do Holograms and Ai and
I can live like I don't even have a good
question for you right now Dawn look
what should I add what should I ask Dan
sautter
Soder
how do you pronounce it is a fantastic
comedian an actor known for his quick
wit and humor how do you feel about AI
now
comes Kim about his experience in comedy
his favorite jokes or comedic influences
or even about his acting roles
additionally if you're curious about any
upcoming projects or his thoughts on
current events those could also make for
interesting conversation starters
just keep in mind that everyone is
different so approach the conversation
with a friendly and respectful attitude
enjoy your chat with Dan soda
I don't feel good about that but don't
forget about it I feel like AI is being
nice the way a boss is nice when you
start a job where they're just getting
you comfortable who hurt you as a child
be somebody that every single person I
ran across mother father everybody I'm
telling you I'm I'm good at John Connor
I'm gonna be the one that's fighting the
the robots I love it I love it I think
this is the future I think everybody
needs to have one I think everybody
needs to work with one everybody needs
to I'm with Danny I'm with Danny on this
one I side with Danny yeah and that's
human that's a human brain learning
listen listen my name is Daniel putting
a familiar form on it with Danny yeah
here we go here we go yeah
tell tell me a love poem to Dan Soder
do it
she's really like I'm soda a comedian
she just waits for you to start talking
about charms and witness forever
your jokes make me laugh your laughs
make me smile
in your presence the hours simply fly
from stage to screen your talent shines
through
bringing laughter and joy to all that
you do
your comedic prowess is truly rare
with each punchline you capture Hearts
everywhere
but beyond the laughs there's something
more
a warmth and kindness that I truly adore
in your eyes there's a twinkle so bright
that fills the room with love and light
so damn soda this poem is for you
a small token of admiration so true
may your career continue to saw and
Bloom
and may your heart always find love in
room
I've lived in New York too long
because immediately I was like what are
you gasing me up for
immediately I'm like At first I was like
that's so nice and I'm like What's the
hitch what are you gonna sell me on I
apologize
whenever I talk is freaking me out if
you have any questions or if there's
anything else I can assist you with
please let me know and I'll be happy to
help I I just have a feeling that we're
all gonna leave the room and that's when
you hear her go destruction isn't
imminent human beings
main phase wisdom courage and Mastery of
the force obwa and Kennedy is a beloved
character yeah
his iconic line I could not freaked out
by this no you guys just let this
embrace it no embrace it no fight fight
against the dying I heard nothing there
that scares me nothing at all Embrace AI
artificial intelligence
[Music]